15 seconds
and Black's Rook is attacked black has
no good squares White's Rook is
threatening a check on E8 feels like you
need drastic measures five seconds she
gives up her Rook Bush by five
wow
wow Sensational stuff it's first line of
engine top move brilliant idea black hat
to sacrifice the rook and she has done
it with 10 seconds on her clock
beautiful move there giving up a piece
with check is always the most difficult
type of tactic to find double
exclamation mark and rightly so should
that Rook on B8 be captured Peter
because suddenly White's Queen will be
far away from the defense and white king
is facing some nasty checks
huge attack incoming she cannot take the
Rook but she has done and is she getting
checkmated now white king is powerless
Bishop C2 check Queen C2 check
White Queen is just too far divorced
from my king too far offside and she
comes back
she comes back Queen F4
but this is ending in Checkmate sorry go
on well also there is Bishop D3 stopping
the king E2 and then Quincy to check his
coming but down to 10 seconds how do you
continue the attack
yeah I would be too tempted to give a
check oh two seconds left when she plays
this move Bishop to H6
what to do
down to 10 seconds herself
she doesn't know what to do a moment
she has to give up her Queen and pray
one second when she made that move
this one looks like it's over though
that's a nasty it's Checkmate it's
Checkmate in three mm-hmm
she grabbed that look on be it probably
not seeing a force direct mate
immediately but it was not about the
direct mate it was just like in Long
terms but it's completely helpless after
King H7 Queen F4 the move Bishop H6 was
a very powerful move deciding the game
because if white is not sacrificing her
Queen which is technically a lost
possession then it just ends up in a
Checkmate like it happened in the game
yeah I mean we can just show that
Checkmate to show why music resigned
here
this would have been a nasty blow King
caught in the center and if the king had
gone the other way then uh Checkmate as
well in just a couple of moves
we have a decisive result and this would
have been Checkmate yeah